.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, TUCKER,
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT THE PRICE AT THE PUMP IS
YET ANOTHER ALL-TIME HIGH.
IN FACT, GAS PRICES NOW HAVE HIT
NEW RECORD HIGHS FOR 17
CONSECUTIVE DAYS.
IT NO END IN SIGHT.
AT THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR A
GALLON OF GAS IS WELL OVER $5
PER GALLON.
IF $5.10.
BY THE WAY, DIESEL COSTS EVEN
MORE.
DESPITE WHAT BIDEN AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD HAVE YOU
BELIEVE, THERE IS NO MYSTERY
SURROUNDING WHY WE HAVE SPIKE IN
GAS PRICES.
THAT'S BEGIN WITH A VERY
IMPORTANT REMINDER WHEN SOMEONE
TELLS YOU SOMETHING, ESPECIALLY
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL ABOUT
BELIEVE THEM.
TWO YEARS AGO ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, JOE BIDEN WHEN HE WASN'T
HIDING IN HIS BUNKER TOLD US
THAT HE WAS A CLIMATE WHERE
YOU'RE.
HE SAID HE WAS A CARD-CARRYING
MEMBER OF THE CLIMATE ALARMIST
CALLED.
HE VOWED TO DESTROY THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY, AND EVEN
THREATENED TO THROW OIL
EXECUTIVES IN JAIL.
HE DREAMED OF A GREEN NEW DEAL
AND PROMISED TO MOVE AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS ALTOGETHER EVEN IF
IT MEANT SACRIFICING HIGH PAYING
CAREER JOBS IN THE ENERGY SECTOR
IN THE PROCESS.
EVEN IF IT CAUSED AMERICANS, YOU
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, DEEP
FINANCIAL PAIN WHICH WE ARE NOW
ALL EXPERIENCING.
IT WAS THIS EXCHANGE BETWEEN
BIDEN AND THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
DURING A DEBATE.
OCTOBER 2020, TAKE A LOOK FOR
YOURSELF.
>> WOULD YOU CLOSE DOWN --
>> I WOULD TRANSITION FROM THE
OIL INDUSTRY, YES.
I WOULD TRANSITION.
IF THAT IS A BIG STATEMENT
BECAUSE I WOULD STOP --
>> WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
>> THE OIL INDUSTRY POLLUTES
SIGNIFICANTLY.
I WOULD SAY HERE IS THE DEAL.
IF YOU LET ME FINISH THE
STATEMENT.
IT HAS TO REPLACE BY RENEWABLE
ENERGY.
OVER OVER TIME.
OVER TIME STOPPED GIVING TO THE
OIL INDUSTRY.
I STOPPED GIVING THEM FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES.
YOU WILL NOT GET FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES TO SOLAR AND WIN.
WHY ARE WE GIVING IT TO THE OIL
INDUSTRY?
>> WE ACTUALLY DO TO SOLAR AND
WIND.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST STATEMENT
BECAUSE BASICALLY WHEN HE SAYING
IS THAT HE'S GOING TO DESTROY
THE OIL INDUSTRY.
WE'LL BE REMEMBERED THAT TEXAS?
PENNSYLVANIA, OKLAHOMA?
>> Sean: IS EVERYBODY
REMEMBERING NOW BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT?
IN THAT MOMENT JOE BIDEN SAID
WHAT HE WAS GOING TO DO AND IT
WASN'T THE FIRST TIME.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN WHEN HE
LEAVES HIS BASEMENT, BIDEN
PROMISED TO TRANSITION AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF WE DON'T STOP USING FOSSIL
FUELS, WE ARE ALL DEAD.
DOING AWAY WITH ANY SUBSIDIES
FOR FOSSIL FUELS.
HOLDING THEM RELIABLE FOR WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE, PARTICULARLY IN
THOSE CASES WHERE YOUR
UNDERSERVED NEIGHBORHOODS, YOU
KNOW THEY DEAL OKAY?
BY THE WAY, IT'LL PUT THEM IN
JAIL.
I WANT YOU TO JUST TAKE A LOOK
OKAY?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE, BUT I
WANT YOU TO LOOK IN MY EYES.
I GUARANTEE YOU, I GUARANTEE YOU
WE ARE GOING TO END FOSSIL FUELS
AND I'M NOT GOING TO COOPERATE.
>> WOULD THERE BE ANY PLACE FOR
FOSSIL FUELS INCLUDING COAL AND
FRACKING IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
>> NO, WE WOULD WORK IT OUT AND
MAKE SURE IT'S ELIMINATED.
>> Sean: END OF FUELS AND
ELIMINATE IT.
WHEN YOU ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THE
WORLD SUPPLY OF A LIFE BLOOD OF
OUR ECONOMY, OIL AND GAS, AND AT
A TIME WHEN DEMAND IS ACTUALLY
GROWING, PRICES GO UP.
AT THAT SIMPLE ECONOMICS 101.
YOU DON'T NEED A HARVARD
BUSINESS DEGREE TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
AT THE TIME, PRESIDENT TRUMP
PREDICTED WHAT WOULD HAPPEN AND
WHAT IS EXACTLY HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
IT TOOK A LOOK AT THIS.
>> YOU'RE PAYING WHAT, $2 PER
GALLON FOR YOUR GASOLINE?
THAT'S LIKE A TAX CUT.
THAT'S BIGGER THAN A TAX CUT.
IF BIDEN GOT IN, YOU'D BE PAYING
$7, $8, $9!
LOOKING TO BUILD SOME MORE
WINDMILLS.
IF GAS PRICES, YOU LIKE THE $2
GAS.
WHAT ABOUT $5, $6?
$7?
LET'S SELL THE CAR.
BIDEN PLAN IS AN ECONOMIC DEATH
SENTENCE.
>> Sean: THE FAMED OUTRAGE
OVER THE MEAN TWEETS, I'LL TAKE
THE MEAN TWEETS AND $2 PER
GALLON GASOLINE ANY DAY.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DID EXACTLY
WHAT HE PROMISED TO DO.
IT KILLED OFF THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE AND DID GIVE A WAIVER
TO THE NORTH STREAM PIPELINE FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT PAID BACK FOR ALL THE
BUSINESS THAT HUNTER AND RUSSIA
DID TOGETHER.
HE ALSO BAND DRILLING.
HE RESTRICTED FRACKING, SLOW
DOWN PRODUCTION WITH A SLEW OF
BURDENSOME REGULATIONS.
WHILE HE CURBED DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION, HE'S HAPPY TO BEG
OTHER COUNTRIES FOR OIL
INCLUDING SOME OF AMERICA'S
WORST ENEMIES.
IRAN, GOING TO MAKE A RUN RICH
AND THEN VENEZUELA RICH AGAIN,
THANK THE SAUDIS AND OPEC TO
PRODUCE MORE OIL.
PLANNING THE TRIP TO SAUDI
AMERICA WITH THE OFF AGAIN THEN
ON AGAIN BEG FOR MORE OIL FROM
THE GULF?
WE'VE GOT MORE NATURAL RESOURCES
HERE.
SOMEHOW, ACCORDING TO THE
CLIMATE CULT, PAYING FOREIGN
DICTATORS AND AMERICAN SWORN
ENEMIES TO PRODUCE THE OIL OUR
ECONOMY NEEDS DESPERATELY.
HOW IS THAT BETTER FOR
MOTHER EARTH AND THE CLIMATE
THAN PRODUCING IT RIGHT HERE AT
HOME?
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
WHILE WE ARE ON THE RECORD OF
THE HIGH PRICES EVERY DAY, WE
EXPERIENCE WHEN EVERY DAY FOR 17
DAYS IN A ROW, ALONG WITH A
PRESIDENT WHO IS UNWILLING OR
UNABLE TO CHANGE COURSE.
HE SO BEHOLDEN TO HIS CLIMATE
RELIGIOUS CULTS.
DOING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, EXPECTING A
DIFFERENT RESULT, THAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY.
ALLOWING THESE POLICIES TO
REMAIN IN PLACE IS INSANE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
BECAUSE JOE ANSWERS TO THE
RADICAL ECO-SOCIALIST NEW GREEN
DEALERS AND HIS OWN PARTY.
WE WILL COMPROMISE OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND BE DEPENDENT ON
OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE WILL ELIMINATE ALL OF THE
HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR.
WE WILL DO NOTHING TO INCREASE
THE WORLD SUPPLY WHICH WOULD
LOWER GAS COSTS DRAMATICALLY AT
THE PUMP.
WE WILL GIVE UP THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO LOWER
INFLATION AND REDUCE THE PRICE
OF EVERY ITEM AND EVERY STORY
THAT WE SHOP AT BY REDUCING THE
DELIVERY COST.
IT COSTS A LOT MORE WHEN THE
18-WHEELERS FILL UP THE TRUCKS
FROM OTHER RIGS WITH DIESEL.
JUST TO CLING FOR THE CLIMATE
RELIGIOUS CULT?
IT'S CLEARLY WAY MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE SUFFERING OF FOREIGN
AMERICANS, MIDDLE-CLASS
AMERICANS, AMERICANS ON FIXED
INCOMES.
TRUTH BE TOLD AT THIS POINT,
IT'S NOT TOTALLY CLEAR THAT THE
PRESIDENT CAN THINK FOR HIMSELF
AT ALL.
WITH HIS POLL NUMBERS CRATERING,
BY THE WAY, REAL CLEAR POLITICS
AVERAGE NOW LOWER THAN AVERAGE.
38% AND BY THE WAY THAT INCLUDES
A VERY FAVORABLE JOE PAUL'S NOT
EXACTLY IN THE WORLD OF REALITY.
WE CALLED HIM OUTLIERS.
DEMOCRATS ARE STARTING TO JUMP
SHIP.
"THE NEW YORK POST" PUT IT, SAY
IT AIN'T JOE.
DEMOCRATIC DOUBTS MOUNTING ON
BIDEN'S 2024 REELECTION RUN.
TOP OBAMA ADVISOR, DAVID AXELROD
SAID, BIDEN'S AGE WAS A MAJOR
RED FLAG.
OCASIO-CORTEZ REFUSED TO SAY
WHETHER OR NOT SHE WOULD SUPPORT
BIDEN IN 2024.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE
FROM THE LIBERAL
"NEW YORK TIMES."
IT SHOULD BIDEN RUN IN 2024?
DEMOCRATIC WHISPERS.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORTS, DOZENS
OF FRUSTRATED DEMOCRATS
OFFICIALS MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND VOTERS ARE EXPRESSING DOUBTS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S ABILITY TO
RESCUE HIS REELING PARTY.
ONE DNC COMMITTEE MEMBER TOLD
THE TIMES "TO SAY OUR COUNTRIES
ON THE RIGHT TRACK WOULD
FLAGRANTLY DEPART FROM REALITY.
"ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," JOE WAS
LASHING OUT AT HIS OWN STAFF AND
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF RON KLA